The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: What
we're going to talk
about today is in
the previous class,
we did a lot of examples
on some data sets.
And they were artificially
generated data sets, which
is a requirement in terms of
if you want to do anything
with big data and
really show stuff,
it can be really difficult
to pass around terabytes
and terabytes of data.
So having data generators
that generate the statistics
that you want or approximate
the statistics that you want
are good to have.
We had a previous lecture
on power law graphs
and talked about a perfect
[AUDIO OUT] is very useful,
and I encourage you to use that.
It's a useful analytic tool.
This one, we're going to
talk about Kronecker graphs
and generation.
Kronecker graphs are used in the
largest benchmark in the world
for benchmarking graph systems.
And then finally,
I'm going to talk
a little bit about performance.
What are the things you
should be aware of when you're
doing systems and building
systems from a performance
perspective, the
kinds of things that
are essentially fundamental
limits of the technology.
So moving forward, let's talk
about the Graph500 benchmark.
So the Graph500
benchmark was created
to provide a
mechanism for timing
the world's most
powerful computers
and see how good they were
on graph type operations.
And so I was
involved and actually
wrote some of the initial
code for this benchmark
about 5 or 10 years ago.
And it's now become
a community effort,
and the code has changed,
and other types of things.
And it's mainly
meant for dealing
with parallel
in-memory computations,
but the benchmark
is actually very
useful for timing databases
or any types of things.
You can do the exact
same operations.
So it generates
data, and then it
has you construct it
in a graph, and then
it goes on to do some
other operations.
And so we've actually
found it to be
a very useful tool
as a very fast,
high-performance data generator.
And if you want to time
inserts of power law data,
it's very useful for that.
This is some older
performance numbers.
But this just shows
essentially here
on a single core of computing
capability, the number
of entries that we're inserting
into a table and the inserts
per second that we're getting.
So the single core
performance here
for this data into
Accumulo, it's
about 20,000 inserts per second.
So there's a one core
database, very, very small.
As you've seen-- we've
even showed last week
on modern servers
where we're getting
several thousand inserts per
second on standard databases.
I'm comparing this also with
just D4M without a database.
If I just have triples and I
construct an associative array,
how fast does it do that?
And so obviously, D4M is
limited by how much memory you
have on your system,
but it just show you
the constructing and
associative array.
And memory is faster
than inserting data
into a database
by a good amount.
And so again, if you could
work with associative arrays
and memory, that's going
to be better for you.
Obviously, though,
the database allows
you to go to very large sizes.
And one of the great
things about Accumulo
is this line stays pretty flat.
You can go on, out, and
out, and out, and out.
That's what it really
prides itself on,
is that-- as you add data,
it might degrade slightly,
but if you're
inserting it right,
that line stays pretty flat.
In the last class,
we did show how
to do parallel inserts
in parallel D4M.
And this shows parallel inserts
here on a single node database,
D4M itself basically taking
this number and scaling it up
and also into the database.
And so here a single
node, single core database
who are getting 100,000
inserts a second with that.
And so that just shows you some
of the parallel expectations,
and when you should use
parallel versions databases.
Again, if you can be in memory,
you want to be in memory.
It's faster.
If you can be in
parallel memory,
you probably want to
be in parallel memory.
That's faster.
But if you have really large
problems, then obviously,
you need to go to the database.
And that's what that's for.
The data in the
graph 500 benchmark
is what we call a
Kronecker graph.
It basically takes a little,
tiny matrix, a little seed
matrix-- in this case,
g-- and you can imagine
what it looks like here.
Imagine this is a
two-by-two matrix here.
You can sort of see, maybe, a
little bit of the structure.
And then it does a
Kronecker product
of that on out to create
and adjacency matrix.
By creating this adjacency
matrix, that creates the graph.
And as a result, it naturally
produces-- this is the result.
It produces something
that naturally looks
like a power law graph here.
And this just
shows you the dots,
shows you the power law
degree distribution of that.
You can see the slope
there generated from this.
I should say one of
the powerful things
about this particular
generator is
you don't have to form the
adjacency matrix to construct
the graph.
So it doesn't require you to
build this gigantic matrix.
It generates the
edges atomically.
If you have many, many
processes all doing this,
as long as they set
their random number seeds
to different
locations, they'll all
be generating perfectly
consistent edges in a larger
graph.
So people have run this
on computers with millions
of cores to do that.
Because the graph generator
is completely-- parallel
allows you to essentially
create a giant graph.
And also, the Kronecker graph
does generate this structure
here, which is these
bumps and wiggles.
And that actually
corresponds to the power k.
So you can count
the number of bumps.
We have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
So this would be a
g to the 8th graph.
So that structure
is visible there,
which is an artificial
feature of the data.
And so one of the things
that's actually occurred now--
because people have
been actually trying
to use this generator because
it's so fast and efficient
to simulate graphs.
And we've basically
said to people,
not really designed to
simulate large graphs,
because it does create these
artificial structures in there.
And that's the reason we develop
the perfect power law method.
Because that's a
much better method
if you're actually trying to
simulate graphs for doing that.
Again, this method
has these advantages
in terms of being
able to generate them.
Another advantage
of these Kronecker
graphs-- and so in this case,
B is my little matrix here
that I'm going to do
Kronecker products of.
In fact, let me remind you about
what a Kronecker product is.
So if I have here
a matrix B, that's
nb by nb, although these
don't have to be square,
and another matrix
C that's nc by mc
doesn't also have to be square.
And when you do the
Kronecker product,
basically what you're
doing is essentially
taking c and multiplying
by the first element,
and having essentially
a block here.
And so it's a way of
essentially expanding
the matrix in both dimensions.
And Jure Leskovec, who's
now a professor at Stanford,
essentially developed
this method back in 2005
for creating these
matrices which
allow you to very naturally
create power law matrices,
and even had tools for
fitting them to data,
which is a useful thing.
Again, its biggest
impact has been
on generating very large graphs,
power law graphs very quickly.
The Kronecker graph itself
has several different types
that I call here, basically,
explicit, stochastic,
and an instance.
So if I just set the
coefficients of the Kronecker
graph to be ones and
zeroes and I Kronecker out,
I will get structures
that look like this.
So this is a Kronecker
graph that essentially
is a bipartite,
essentially starting
with a-- what you can call a
star graph and then a diagonal.
So that's 1.
That's g1.
Then I Kronecker product
again, g2 and g3,
and I get these different
structure 0 1 matrices.
And so it's only 0's and
1's, and so the structure
and the connections
are very obvious.
And this is actually
useful for doing theory.
So you can actually do
a fair amount of theory
on the structure of graphs
using the 0 1 matrices.
And in fact, there's
a famous paper
by Van Loan on
Kronecker products.
And basically, the paper
is full of identities
of Kronecker products that--
the eigenvalues of the Kronecker
product of two matrices is
the same as the Kronecker
product of their eigenvalues,
and a whole series
of those things.
And so what's nice is
if you compute something
on just the small matrix
g, you can very quickly
compute all the properties of
the Kronecker product matrix,
and that makes it very
nice for doing theory.
And so there's times when
you want to understand
the structure of these things.
Very useful theoretical
tool for doing that.
If instead, we use our
C graph, instead of
it being 1's and 0's,
it contains, say,
numbers between 0 and 1
that are probabilities,
the probability of creating
an edge between those two
vertices.
And we multiply that on out.
You get, essentially, a giant
probability matrix showing
the probability of edges.
These are the same, but here
we see we have differences.
We don't just have 0's and 1's.
We have values
between 0's and 1's.
And then using the Kronecker
generation technique,
we essentially draw instances
from this probability matrix
over here.
So this allows us
to randomly sample.
So when you're talking
about Kronecker graphs,
there's three
different types here.
This is very easy
to do theory on.
You can do theory on
this, too, but it tends
to be a little bit more work-y.
And then likewise, when
you're doing simulations,
usually you end up with
Kronecker graphs like this.
As an example of the
kind of theory we can do,
one of the nicest graphs to
work with are bipartite graphs.
So a bipartite graph is
two sets of vertices,
and each vertex has a
connection to every vertex
in the other set, but they
don't have any connections
amongst themselves.
And so here, I'm showing you
a bipartite or star graph,
so basically one
set of vertices here
and another set
of vertices here.
And all the vertices have
connections to those vertex,
but they have no
connections themselves.
And this is the adjacency
matrix of that graph.
And here is another
bipartite graph.
It's a 3 1 set.
And if I Kronecker product
two bipartite graphs,
the result is two
more bipartite graphs.
So as we see here, we've
created this one here
and this one here.
And so in my notation, I'll
say B 5, 1 is a bipartite.
That's basically--
I'm saying I have
a matrix that's a 5, 1 bipartite
graph, 3, 1 bipartite graph.
And within some
permutation, they
produce a matrix that is the
union of a 15, a 1, and a 3, 5.
And this result actually was
first shown by a professor
by the name of Weichsel in 1962.
And there was actually
a little flurry
of activity back in the 1960s
with this whole algebraic view
of graph theory, which
was very productive,
but then it all died off.
And after the lecture, I can
tell you why that happened.
But now it's all coming
back, which is nice.
So it took us 50 years
to rediscover this work.
But there's actually
a whole book on it
with lots of
interesting results.
But then this just shows
you the general result here.
For any two bipartite graphs,
if I Kronecker product
them together, they are
under some permutation
equal to two other
bipartite graphs.
And this naturally shows
you how the power law
structure gets built up when you
Kronecker product these graphs.
So basically, you
had this and this.
And there, we basically-- that's
the super node vertex here,
this 1, 1 vertex.
And these are the
lower degree pieces.
And then these
other vertices here
are the singleton vertices.
So you can see as
you naturally product
these bipartite graphs
together, you naturally
create these power law graphs.
An example-- I won't really
belabor the details here--
you can compute the
degree distribution.
And this is all-- there's a long
chapter on this in the book.
Basically, you can
compute analytically
the degree distributions
of Kronecker
producing bipartite graphs.
This shows you the
formula for doing that.
And here is the actual
degree distribution
with the binomial
coefficients for that.
And so a very useful thing.
You can a priori do that.
This shows you the results.
So if I have a Kronecker
product of a bipartite graph n
equals 5 comma 1, and I take
it out to the 10th power,
this is the result
is this blue line.
And what you see is that
you get-- if you connect
the last vertex and this
vertex-- essentially
our poor man's
alpha-- or connected
any one of these
other sets here,
they have a constant
slope of negative 1.
So that's a theoretical
result is that they
have this constant slope.
And that's true down here, k to
the 5, other types of things.
So we do get this bowing effect.
So it's not perfect
with respect to that.
But you can see
how this power law
is baked in to the
Kronecker generator, which
is a very nice thing.
This shows a sample.
We basically created a
4 by 1 bipartite graph
and then sampled it.
And so this shows the
stochastic instance.
There's about a
million vertices here.
Shows you that.
And then these
curves here show--
when we take the
stochastic graph
and analytically compute
what the expected value
of every single degree
is assuming a Poisson
distribution, and you can
see that we get pretty much
a perfect fit here all the way
out, except to the very end
here.
And this is where you get some
pretty interesting statistics
going on.
In theory, no one vertex--
this is your distribution.
No one vertex should actually
be attracting this many nodes.
But you have so many
vertices with one of them
that have this problem.
When you sum them all
together, one of them
gets to be chosen
to be the winner.
And it's what pops it up here.
So all the way out
to the-- our fit
is very good all the way
out to the super node,
and we have this
difference here.
And this is where the Poisson
statistics begin to fail.
So again, lots of opportunities
for a very interesting theory
there.
So that's just pure
bipartite graphs.
But bipartite graphs have
no inter-group connections.
So we can actually
create something
that looks like
a power law graph
and see all the community
substructure very clearly.
But those communities are
not connected in any way.
And so to create connections
to the communities,
we have to add the identity
matrix down the diagonal.
And that well then now connect
all our sub bipartite graphs
together.
So this just shows
here-- so we basically
take our bipartite
graph plus the identity,
and that's essentially
this combinatorial sum here
of the individual
bipartite graphs there.
Again, where in quotes, it
means that there's a permutation
you need to actually
make this all work out.
We actually do the computation.
This shows the 4, 1 bipartite
plus an identity bipartite
graph out to the fourth power.
So you see here you're
going to get 1, 2.
You can compute it on out there.
And what you see is this
recursive structure,
almost fractal like structure.
So that's a nice way to view it.
That's one way to see it.
But you don't really see
the bipartite substructure
in there.
It's hard to see
what's going on there.
Well, since this is
analytic, we can actually
compute a permutation that
says please recover all
those bipartite substructures.
And so in the software,
actually, [INAUDIBLE],
we have a way of
basically computing
a permutation of this
that basically regroups
all our bipartite groups here.
And then you can see all the
bipartite cores or bipartite
pieces, and then all
the interconnections
between those core
bipartite pieces.
To give you a better sense
of what that really means,
here, basically we have b to
the i to the third power here.
That's what it looks like.
If we just subtract out
the first and second order
components, then we're left with
these are the interconnecting
pieces.
We can see that much
better when we permute it.
So here is the permutation
of just the bipartite piece,
and that shows you these
core bipartite chunks
that are in the graph.
We then do the second term,
which is b kron b kron i.
So this is the second.
Now you can see that
this creates connections
between these groups.
And then likewise, if you do
the next one-- so b kron i b,
that shows you the connections
between these groups,
and then ibb shows you
the different connections
in these groups.
So each set of--
when we take b plus i
and multiply it
out and look at all
those different combinations
of the different multiplies
there, there's the core piece,
which is just b kron to the 3,
and that creates this
core structure here,
which is these dense pieces, and
then all the other polynomials
are essentially creating
interconnections between that.
So you can get a really
deep understanding
of the core structure and how
those things connect together,
which can be very interesting.
But we can compute these
interconnected structures
fairly nicely.
Here's a higher order example
going out to the fifth.
But we can compute the
structure, this chi structure
here, which is essentially
a summary of these,
by just looking at a two-by-two.
So we can compute
all the structures
of the interconnections
by just looking.
Since we have a
bipartite thing, we
can collapse all those
pieces down and just have
a two-by-two.
So we have here a little tiny
version of this structure here.
It shows you that.
Likewise, this structure
here is summarized by that,
and this structure here
is summarized by that.
So you can get
complete knowledge,
not just at the low level scale,
but at all scales if you wanted
to say I want to
look at the blocks
and how the edges are
connected in detail,
or if I just want to
consider things in big blocks
and connect them, I can do
that very nicely as well.
And again, we can compute the
degree distributions as well.
So this just shows b
kron to the k, and then
b plus the second order
terms, and then moving on out.
And actually, what you see is
by adding this identity matrix,
all it does is slide the
degree structure over.
It also does change
the slope a little bit
here by adding this
identity matrix along.
So it's steeper
than the original.
And you can do other
types of things.
Here's something we did
in iso-parametric ratios.
I won't belabor that.
But it essentially is a way
of computing the surface
to volume of subgraphs.
And we can compute
this analytically.
And we see that the
iso-parametric ratio
of a bipartite
subgraph is constant,
but the half bipartite graph
has this property here.
And just to summarize
here-- and this
is done a great deal
in the chapter--
this just shows
different examples
of the theoretical
results you can compute
for a bipartite graph or a
bipartite plus an identity,
the degree distribution.
Betweenness centrality is a
fairly complicated metric.
We actually haven't figured
it out for this one,
or I didn't bother to
figure it out for this one.
I can compute the
diameter very nicely.
You can compute the eigenvalues.
And the iso-parametric
are just all examples
of a kind of theoretical
work you can do.
And again, I think
it's very useful
if you want to understand
the substructure
and how the different
parts of a power law graph
might interact with each other.
So that just talks
about Kronecker graphs
and what are the bases
of these benchmarks.
And now I'm going to get
into some benchmarks again
themselves.
So this is just to remind folks.
This just shows some
examples of when
you're doing benchmarking
of inserts into a database.
Normally, when you do
parallel computing,
you have one parameter, which is
how many parallel processes are
you running at the same time.
And so most of
your scaling curves
will be with respect
to, in this case,
the number of
concurrent processes
that you're running
at one time here.
I think we're going
up to 32 here.
That's the standard parameter
in parallel computing.
When you have parallel
databases involved,
now you have a couple of
additional parameters, which
just make it that
much more stuff
you have to keep in your head.
Essentially, in
this case, Accumulo
calls its individual
data servers
tablet servers, so you have
to be aware of how many tablet
servers you have.
So that's another parameter.
So you have to create
separate curves here.
This is our scaling curve with
a number of ingest processes
into one tablet server versus
number of ingest processes
into six tablets servers.
And as you can see, not
a huge difference here
at the small end.
But eventually, the one tablet
server database levels off
while the other one
keeps on scaling.
And so this is very tricky.
If you want to do
these kind of results,
you have to be aware of
both of these parameters
in order to really
understand what you're doing.
There's also a third
parameter which
is generally true
of most databases,
and Accumulo is no
exception, which
is that you're inserting a
table into a parallel database,
that table is going to be split
amongst the different parallel
servers in the database.
And that will have a big
impact on performance.
How many splits you
have-- because you're not
going to be able to take
advantage of-- if you have
fewer splits than the number
of database server nodes,
then you're not taking
advantage of those.
And then how balanced
those splits are.
Is the data going in
uniformly into those things?
And so this just shows you
an example of an 8 tablet
server Accumulo
doing the inserts
with no splits versus doing it,
in this case, with 35 splits.
And you see there's a rather
large impact on the performance
there.
So D4M actually has tools.
We didn't really go into them.
But if you look at
the documentation,
we're allowing you to do splits.
The databases we've
given you access to
are all single node
databases, so we've
made your life, in
a certain sense,
a little bit easier
that you don't
have to worry about splits.
But it is something-- as
you work on larger systems,
you have to be very
aware of the splits.
Another thing that's
often very important
when you're inserting
into a database
is the size of
the chunks of data
you're handing to the database.
This is sometimes
called the block size.
This is a very
important parameter.
Blocking of programs
is very important.
Probably the key thing we
do in optimizing any program
is coming up, finding
what the right block
size is for a system.
Because it almost always has a
peak around some number here.
And so this just
shows the impact
of block size on the performance
rate here for Accumulo.
And the nice about
D4M, there's actually
a parameter you can set for the
table which will say how many
bytes I want to set.
I think the default is
500 kilobytes, which
is a lot smaller than
I would've thought,
but it's a number
that we found tends
to be fairly optimal across
a wide range of things.
Typically, when you do
inserts into a database,
you're like, well, I want
to give you the biggest
chunk that I can and move on.
And Accumulo and probably
a lot of databases
actually like to get
data in smaller chunks
than you might think.
Basically, what's
happening then is
if you're giving it
the right size chunks,
then it all fits in cache, and
any sorting and other types
of operations it has
to do on that data can
be done much more efficiently.
So this just shows
another parameter
you have to be worried about.
If you do everything right--
and I showed these results
before-- these are the kind
of results you can get.
This shows essentially on an 8
node system-- fairly powerful,
24 cores per node getting the
4 million inserts or entries
per second that we saw, which
is, to our knowledge, again,
the world record
holder for this.
That talks about inserts.
Another thing that we also
want to look at is queries.
So as I said before, Accumulo
is a row-based store, which
means if you give
it a row key, it
will return the result
in constant time.
And so that's true.
So we've done a bunch
of queries here,
lots of different concurrent
processes all querying
at the same time.
And you can see the response
time is generally, they say,
around 50 milliseconds,
which is great.
And this is the full
round trip time.
A lot of this could have
been network latency,
for all we know.
So that's what you expect.
That's what Accumulo does.
If you do row queries,
then you get constant time.
Now, as we've
talked about before,
we do our special
exploded transpose schema,
which essentially give this
performance for both row
and column queries.
But if you have a table
where you haven't done that
and you are going
to query a column,
it's a complete
scan of the table.
And so you see here-- when
you want to do a column query,
the performance is just
going to go up and up and up,
because they're all just
doing more and more scans,
and the system can only
scan at a certain rate.
So that's, again,
the main reason
why we do these special schemas
is to avoid this performance
penalty.
So finally, in talking
about performance,
let's talk a little bit
about D4M performance itself.
If you write your D4M
programs optimally--
and this sometimes
takes a while to get to,
because usually you
don't quite have the--
or I should say, in the most
elegant way possible, again,
this sometimes requires
some understanding.
Most applications
end up becoming
a combination of
matrix multiplies
on these associative arrays.
Now, it's usually not the
first program I write,
but usually, it's
the last one I write.
It finally dawns on me how to do
the entire complicated analytic
and all its queries as a
series of special sparse matrix
multiplies, which then allows
us to maximally leverage
the underlying libraries
which have been
very optimized to do--
it's basically not
calling any of my code.
It's just calling the MATLAB
sparse matrix multiply routine,
which is further calling the
sparse BLAS, which are heavily
optimized by the
computing vendors,
and likewise are
calling sort routines.
So the thing you have
to understand, though,
is that sparse matrix multiply
has fundamental hardware
limits depending on the kinds
of multiplies you're doing here.
And we have a whole program
that basically times all these
and generates them.
So if you ever want to get what
your fundamental limits are,
we have a set of
programs that will
run all these benchmarks
for you and show you
what you can expect.
And this shows you,
basically, the fraction
of the theoretical
peak performance
of the processor as a
function of the total memory
on that processor.
So this is all single core,
single processor benchmarks.
So as you can see here, this
is dense matrix multiply.
And it's 95% efficient.
If I was to build a
piece of special purpose
hardware and a memory subsystem
for doing dense matrix
multiply, it would be
identical to the computers
that you all have.
Your computers have
been absolutely designed
to do dense matrix multiply.
And for good or bad,
that's just the way it is.
The caching structure,
the matrix multiply units,
the vectorization units, they're
all designed to-- they're
identical to a custom
built matrix multiply unit.
And so we get enormously
high performance here,
95% peak on dense
matrix multiply.
Unfortunately, that hardware
architecture and everything
we do it for dense
matrix multiply
is the opposite of
what we would do
if we built a computer for
doing sparse matrix multiply.
And that's why we have, when we
go from dense matrix multiply
to sparse matrix multiply, this
1,000x drop in performance.
And this is not getting
better with time.
This is getting worse with time.
And there's nothing
you can do about it.
That is just what
the hardware does.
Now, it's still better to
do sparse matrix multiply
than to convert it to
dense, because you're still
a net win by not computing
all those zeros that you would
have in a very sparse matrix.
So it's still a significant
win in execution time
to do your calculation
on sparse matrices
if they are sparse,
but not otherwise.
And then-- so that's that.
This shows the
associative array.
So the top one is MATLAB dense,
MATLAB sparse, D4M associative
array.
And we worked very hard to
make the D4M associative
array be a constant factor
below the core sparse.
So you're really getting
performance that's
pretty darn close to that.
And so generally, doing
sparse matrix multiplies
on the associative arrays
works out pretty well.
But again, there is still about
21% efficient of the hardware.
And then the final
thing is we have
these special sparse matrix
multiplies where we concatenate
the keys together.
If you remember way back when we
did the bioinformatics example,
we could do special
matrix multiplies
that essentially preserved
where the data came from.
If we correlated
two DNA sequences,
we would have a
matrix that would show
the IDs of the DNA sequence.
And if we did these
special matrix multiplies,
the values would then hold the
exact DNA sequences themselves
that were the matches.
Well, there's a
performance hit that
comes with holding that
additional information, all
of this string information.
It may be one day we'll be
able to optimize this further,
although we've actually
optimized it a fair bit
already.
And so there's
another factor of 100.
And it looks like
this is just, again,
fundamentally
limited by the speed
at which the hardware will
do sparse matrix multiply
and the speed at which
it can do string sorting.
That's essentially
the two routines
that all these
functions boil down to,
is sparse matrix multiply
and string storing.
And those are essentially
hardware limited.
Those are very
optimized functions.
So this just gives you a way.
I think it's always--
the first thing
we do when we run a program
is if we want to optimize it,
we'll write the program
and run it, get a time,
and then we'll try and figure
out based on this type of data,
well, what's the theoretical
best we could do?
Given what this calculation
is dominated by,
what is the best we can do?
Because if the best we could
do-- the theoretical peak
for what we were doing was
1,000 times better than what
we're doing, that tells
us, you know what?
If we have to invest
time in optimization,
it probably is time well spent.
Going from being 1,000x below
whatever the best you can do
getting to 100x usually
doesn't take too much trouble.
Usually, you can find
what that issue is
and you can correct it.
Likewise, going from 100x
to 10x is still usually
a worthwhile thing to do.
If you're at 10% of the
best that you can do,
then you begin to
think hard about,
well, do I really want to chase?
I'm never going to
probably do better than 50%
of what the best is, or
maybe even 30% or 40%.
Usually, there's a
lot of effort that
goes into going from
10% of peak performance
to 50% of performance.
But going from 0.1%
of peak performance
to 1% of peak
performance is usually
profile the code, aha, I'm doing
something wrong here, fix it,
done.
And so this is something
that's a part of our philosophy
in doing optimization, and why
we spend so much time running
benchmarks and
understanding where--
because it tells
us when to stop.
If someone says, well,
will this be faster,
and you can say no, it won't
be faster, you're done.
Or, ah, no, we think
in a few weeks' time,
we can really make
it a lot better.
So very useful thing, and
that's why benchmarking
is a big part of what we do.
So finally, I want
to wrap up here.
This was one of the first
charts I showed you,
and hopefully now it
makes a lot more sense.
This shows you the easy path
toward solving your problems
in signal processing
on databases.
And if you look at your
problem as one of how much data
I want to process and how much--
what the granularity of access
is, well, if I don't have
a lot of data and I'm
accessing it at a very
small granularity,
well, then I should just do it
in the memory of my computer.
Don't mess around with files.
Don't mess around
with databases.
Keep your life simple.
Work it there.
If the data request gets high,
memory is still the best.
Whether you're doing
little bits or big bits,
working out of main memory
on a single processor,
generally, for the most part,
is where you want to be.
If you're going to be getting
to larger amounts of data
but having a fairly
large request size,
then using files,
reading those files in
and out-- so
basically, if I have
a lot of data I want to
process, it won't fit
into serial memory, we'll write
it out into a bunch of files,
just read them in, process
them, move onto the next file
is the right thing to do.
Or spread it out in parallel.
Run a bunch of nodes and use
the RAM in each one of those.
That's still the
best way to do it.
You could also do
that in parallel.
You can have parallel programs
reading parallel files, too.
So if you have really
enormous amounts of data
and you're going to be reading
the data in large chunks,
then you want to use parallel
files, parallel computing.
That's going to give
you better performance.
And it's just going to be easy.
Have a lot of files.
Each program reads into sets
of files, processes its set.
Very easy to do.
And we have lots of support
in our [INAUDIBLE] system
for doing those
types of problems.
It's the thing that
most people do.
However, if you have
a large amount of data
and you want to be accessing
small fractions of it randomly,
that's when you want
to use the database.
That is the use case
for the database.
And there are
definitely times when
we have that case where
we want to do that.
But you want to
build towards it.
A lot of times when you're
doing analytics or algorithm
development, you tend to
be in these cases first.
And so rather than bite off
the complexity associated
with dealing with a database,
use these tools first.
But then eventually, there may
be a time where you actually
have to use the database.
And hopefully, one thing
you get out of this course
is understanding this
nuance type of thing.
Because a lot of people say,
we need a parallel database.
Why?
We have a lot of data.
All right.
That's great.
Well, what do you want to do?
We want to scan over
the whole thing.
Well, that's just going to
be a lot of data really slow.
So people will do that.
They'll load a bunch
of data in the system.
They're like, well,
but nothing is faster.
It's like, well,
yeah, if you're going
to scan over a significant
fraction the database,
it will be slower-- certainly
slower than loading it
into the memories of
a bunch of computers,
and even slower than just
having a bunch of files
and reading them into memory.
And increasingly nowadays,
you're talking about
this is millions of entries.
There's a lot of things that
were databases that we have,
like the lab's LDAP server.
It's like 30,000 entries.
We have a database for it.
You could send it around
an Excel spreadsheet
and pretty much do
everything with that.
Or the entire release review
query, or the phone book,
or whatever-- these are all
now, by today's standards,
microscopic data sets
that can trivially
be stored in a single
associative array in something
like this and manipulated
to your heart's content.
So there's a lot of data sets
that are big to the human
but are microscopic to
the technology nowadays.
So this is usually
millions of entries.
This might be hundreds
of millions of entries.
Definitely, when you
really need-- often,
you're talking about
billions of entries
when you're getting here to
the point where you really
need a database.
The exception to
this being if you're
in a program that requires--
many of our customers
will say the database
is being used.
This is where the data is.
It's in no other place.
So for integration
purposes, then you
throw all this out the window.
If they say, look, this
is where the data is
and that's the only way you
can get it, then of course.
But that still doesn't mean
you might be like, yeah, well,
you're going to store
it in the database,
but I'm going to store it
in /temp, and work on it,
and then put my results
back in the database,
because I know that what I'm
doing is going to be better.
There's no-- as
they say, we don't
want to be too proud to win.
Just because some people,
it's like, we have a database,
and everything must be
purely done in the database.
Or some people are like,
we have a file system,
and everything must be purely
done in the file system.
Or we have this language
and everything--
the right tool for
the job, pulling
them together, totally fine.
It's a quick way to
get this work done
without driving yourself crazy.
So with that, I'll
come to the end.
I have one code example which
is relatively short to show you.
But again, parallel graphs
are the dominant type
of data we see.
Graph500 relies on
this Kronecker graphs.
Kronecker graph theory is a
great theoretical framework
for looking at stuff.
You get all the
identity benefits
that come with Kronecker
product eigenvalues.
If you're into that,
I certainly suggest
you read the Van
Loan paper, which
is also the seminal work
on Kronecker products.
And I don't think anyone has
written a followup to him,
because everyone is like,
yep, covered it there.
It's about 12, 15 pages.
Covered all the properties
of Kronecker products.
We can do parallel computing
in D4M via pMATLAB.
And again,
fundamentally, if you've
implemented your
algorithms correctly,
they're limited by hardware,
by fundamental aspects
of the hardware.
There are limitations.
It's important to
know what those are
and to be aware of them.